la llegada de la vacuna contra el co bit
19 américa latina avanza tímidamente
chile confirmó la aprobación de
emergencia para el fármaco de facer y
bayonne tec y esperan las primeras
20.000 dosis en los próximos días los
primeros en vacunarse van a ser los
trabajadores de la salud que trabajan en
unidades de cuidados intensivos con
pacientes críticos luego seguiremos con
las personas que están desplegadas en el
combate contra la pandemia de
coronavirus y con los adultos mayores y
los enfermos crónicos
argentina uno de los pocos países de la
región con capacidad para producir
algunas de las vacunas recibiría 300 mil
dosis del sputnik que llegarían el 24 de
diciembre y serían destinadas a los
mayores de 60 años en caso de que su uso
sea aprobado en rusia así la región más
afectada por el coronavirus busca
delinear un esquema de vacunación pese a
las dificultades de financiación y
acceso a los fármacos con las potencias
acaparando las primeras dosis de la
vacuna la onu repitió la necesidad de
garantizar una distribución equitativa
de la inmunización
en países que han comprado más vacunas
que el volumen de las ofertas en ese
sentido
por supuesto que los gobiernos tienen la
obligación de proteger a sus pueblos
pero no pueden hacerlo siendo los que
están protegidos y la naturaleza siempre
conecta saca howes strikes back para
impulsar la compra y distribución de las
vacunas el banco interamericano de
desarrollo anunció que movilizará mil
millones de dólares extra en ayuda a
países de américa latina y el caribe que
se suman a los cerca de
200 millones comprometidos en 2020